what are the chances that i don't get
kicked off twitter and youtube and
facebook just for talking to you
oh i think you have about a ten percent
chance a good solid ten percent
ten percent getting kicked off for ten
percent step ten percent staying on
actually
you know
big day around here i'm about to
interview president donald j trump we
are doing a sit-down although it's a
slightly different sit-down because he
is doing it via the phone the the
classic style of interviewing uh from an
undisclosed location but before we start
i want to say one thing which is that
his team made it very clear i can ask
him absolutely anything nothing is off
the record nothing is to be hidden or
not to be asked and will i get booted
off youtube for this i suppose we will
find out so here we go
my interview with president donald j
trump all right president donald trump
welcome to the reuben report
well thank you very much david great
great to be with you
uh so president what are the chances
that i don't get kicked off twitter and
youtube and facebook just for talking to
you
oh i think you have about a ten percent
chance a good solid ten percent
ten percent getting kicked off for ten
percent no no ten percent staying on
actually uh you know it's uh
it's crazy this is a crazy world and uh
let's see what all happens i think
they're over playing their hand but
we'll find out about that dave
yeah so do you miss twitter that seems
to be the big question that everyone
wants to know that was your thing do you
miss it at all
so something happened that's i think
you've seen and that's very interesting
i do press releases like i used to you
know the circle goes round and round
right i do press releases and it seems
that a lot of people are waiting for
those press releases
and if you look at the of all places the
new york times did a story a week ago
about
the circulation of what i'm saying is
essentially as big it's very big and the
word is getting out i did a couple of
them today
i like because i'm not confined as to a
number of characters but you know the
number of characters you don't want to
keep it too long anyway okay that's one
thing we all learned maybe from that no
i i think uh i think we're doing very
well with that being said i'll be on
social media in the not too distant
future we're looking at a lot of options
we had
hundreds of millions of people you know
if you look at uh we had 91 on one site
we had 10 and another we had 36 on
another we had potus
we have uh a lot of people and a lot of
people on facebook
and i i hear it's become very boring to
be honest and i hear in particular
twitter has become very very boring and
a lot of conservative voices have gotten
off some have been thrown out and a lot
of them have gotten off
and i hear twitter is not doing well and
it's lost his voice and when i started
there like 11 or 12 years ago it was not
a success i mean it was not a i don't
know it was going to make it but it was
not a success it became
very successful
and i think you're going to see a lot of
people are going to be finding other
other there's a lot of platforms out
there that's what we're looking at
getting the right platform a perfect
platform and i think uh you'll see
something fairly soon yeah that's great
to hear and as you may know i've been
talking to to some of your guys about
locals.com which is the tech company i
started so we shall see good uh so you
know i've told my audience many times
that one of the reasons that i
uh did i didn't support you in 2016 but
then i did in 2020 was that i started
going back and watching old videos of
you on oprah and on david letterman and
on phil donahue and i realized that you
were basically saying the exact same
things 30 years ago that you're saying
now and what that made me wonder was
sort of
did you always you know they would
always ask you oprah would say oh you
should run for president or donahue
would say it but did you always feel
that somebody else was going to do it
and then you just got pinned into doing
it because you didn't seem to really
want to do it actually you kind of
wanted somebody else to do it from the
way i realized it's a great nobody's
ever asked me the question that way and
it's very interesting yeah i assume that
somebody else would do it because people
cannot be that stupid to be taken
advantage of by
china and in particular at that time if
you go back 20 or 30 years it was japan
was really doing a number on i said it's
all the same and frankly it hasn't
changed because whether it's china japan
or many others i mean it's
they're all taken but china obviously
right now is the head of the pack
and i always felt that somebody else
said nobody's ever asked it this way
i've always felt that somebody else
would do it
and they didn't and it went for a long
time you know those interviews and one
thing you have to say dave if nothing
else i was consistent i mean it was i've
seen it too where i've seen a recently a
replay of some of the statements and
they're almost identical to what i say
now and i was right i was right we have
now
30 trillion in debt
we have a country that is just that's
just ridiculous what's going on in so
many ways i talk about the border even
then people coming in
and you know the wrong people coming in
in many cases and you see what's
happening with the prisons are being
emptied out in other countries and
they're coming into our country
and i i was uh
yeah very consistent it's very
interesting
yeah when did you realize that you were
gonna fully have to say what you thought
because when i started going to some of
your rallies and i'm here in crazy los
angeles i was going to the trump rallies
in beverly hills and it was a joy fest
like it was it was truly unbelievable i
couldn't believe it and the main thing
people would say to me when they would
come they'd say dave you know i'm just
sick of being called a racist and a
homophobe and a bigot and everything
else and i met these people these were
the nicest joyest happiest decent
americans ever but when did you realize
that you were just gonna have to sort of
walk through that fire and take those
those labels
so a lot of people think i was gonna run
like for a long time you know they were
asking me that question 30 years ago as
you would say and oprah was and donahue
was and they were all doing it and
and i'd give the answer that i doubt it
because believe it or not dave i'm a
very honest person and you know i'm not
sure that you can be honest and be in
politics okay and i never really thought
i was going to do it a lot of people
thought i was going to do it eight years
ago 12 years ago
i think probably it really hit me when
i turned down a big extension on the
apprentice where you know the show was a
very big success i did it for
14 seasons can you believe it
and then schwarzenegger i miss joan
rivers i miss joan rivers man she was
she was the best
oh yeah she wanted to come on and they
all wanted to come on i watch erin
burnett you know now but she would beg
me to go down the show she she was on
three or four times she would virtually
beg me to be on the apprentice and now i
watch her hit from you know all sides on
msdnc i don't watch her very much but i
see she's on there and i assume she says
nothing but bad but she would beg to be
on as as did others as did many others
but the show was a great success
and they wanted to extend it
a lot like at
the highest level they came over to my
office and i said no i gotta i have to
do this i have to run for president and
they thought i was kidding
they didn't want to hear it they wanted
to extend the show they ended up getting
arnold schwarzenegger who failed badly
as you know is often like a matter of
minutes and they also during the time
they get martha stewart and she failed
but we had a great success and it was
for many years and i said no and you
know when you turn down a prime time
show long-term extension
it's a lot of money no matter how rich
you are but it's a lot of money
and a lot of prestige
and i turned them down the top
executives of nbc came over and they
wanted to make a deal and i turned them
down and i guess so that was really
when i thought i was going to do it and
then of course the famous uh write down
the escalator
and that was it if that was it once i
wrote down the escalator with our great
first lady that uh that turned out to be
it
when did you realize how connected the
sort of mainstream media was to the
swamp you know you were talking about
draining the swamp and obviously the
media was going after you and you
started punching back and republicans or
conservatives or people on the right
usually don't punch back did yeah did
you realize it was it by the time you
were president that you fully realized
or it was really was it that first
debate
no i thought it was bad frankly but i
never knew it was this bad and now it's
worse than ever before it's now it's so
ridiculous i mean you see uh where uh
biden gets up and says things that
nobody can believe or doesn't say things
and they say could that be fdr fdr great
speaker
and uh you know now it's it's out of
control but
uh i've always known that they were
shaky but i used to get great press you
know before i ran for i guess that's
probably one of the reasons i won before
i ran for president i got a lot of great
press i was getting
i was the king i was getting pressed
like nobody
and uh you know i did fine but i also
understood
uh
where and how they were functioning as
much as you can nobody understands the
press fully to be honest with you i
don't care how well you do with it but
once i announced and when i made the
first speech in trump tower once i get
down from the escalator i will tell you
uh
i would say the press turned radically
different and now they become very
corrupt i mean they're really corrupt
it's uh it's a terrible thing to watch
we don't have freedom of the press
anymore we don't have free press or fair
press and we have a very very corrupt
press and and you don't even have to get
into the argument although you say
plenty you have strong opinions on it
but we have a very very corrupt media
yeah no they're they're long gone
they're activists not journalists
they're gunzo they're they're guns we're
doing a big one in uh ohio on saturday
night and people are already lined up
and you know there's just been a great
connection to the people i've had a
great connection to the people and it's
amazing because
when you get virtually a hundred percent
bad press and fox is a whole different
ballgame from what it was too by the way
but when you get a hundred percent
anti-press it's just uh
look you have some really great great
people who should have gotten the
pulitzers you have people that called
russia russia russia exactly right they
don't get the pulitzers they give
pulitzer prizes to people that were
totally wrong totally wrong it's a
disgrace but when you have that and it's
amazing that
even in the last election i get far more
votes in the last election and did far
better than i did in the first election
in 2016.
and it's amazing that you can have the
press so against you big tech against
you and you end up getting 75 million
votes which is the highest anybody's
ever gotten as a sitting president it's
it's pretty amazing
but what it shows you is that
the people of our country get it
they really get it it's pretty amazing
because the left wants to use state
power in a way that generally speaking
the right doesn't want to or at least
that you don't want to
if we're to go on this dystopian future
idea are you worried that
if these guys really take power
i mean they're going to start jailing
political opponents they are going to
use we know they've already used the irs
to do all sorts of crazy things i mean
these are things that are sort of
conspiracy theories and then suddenly at
this point nothing feels like a
conspiracy theory but it it's all
justified
in the there's a self-righteousness to
it we're right anyone who disagrees is
evil
therefore anything is justified to
suppress the evil you see that with
cancer culture where people go
like get driven out
out of the public discourse look when i
was
in college i was a college debater yes i
was one of the cool kids um
but
so i was in college i was the the
chairman of the conservative group in in
the debate debate society and and one of
my closest friends was the head of the
liberal group and we would have
arguments about free enterprise and
socialism like what works what actually
benefits humanity and actually that
question is an important question
too often people start with the
assumption the other side wants humanity
to suffer
if we start with the premise okay most
people of goodwill would like people to
be happier and more well-off and more
prosperous we start with that premise
then we can have a conversation about
okay
what systems produce
more prosperity more opportunity it's
it's you know
a couple years ago i did three cnn town
hall debates with bernie sanders yep
and and they were 90 minutes long and
bernie look to bernie's credit he's an
unabashed socialist i disagree with him
but he's honest and we can have a
conversation about
you know socialism i think if you look
across the world
it doesn't work it's produced misery
poverty suffering
death
um you know my family fled cuba and so
i'm more than happy to take the american
free enterprise system
or as the left derisively calls it
capitalism
and put it up next to communism or
socialism or any dictatorship they've
implemented in every any country on
earth and people are better off they
have more opportunity and
in particular there's the mobility
you know you look at the dystopian
dystopian worlds one of the elements of
it is everyone is frozen in their place
socialist countries communist countries
there are rich people
they're powerful people what you don't
see is new rich people what you don't
see
you know when my dad
in 1957 was a teenage kid from cuba
couldn't speak english
washing dishes making 50 cents an hour
why did he come to america
because this is a country where you
could be a teenage kid washing dishes
and climbed
that socioeconomic ladder and it kind of
worked out for his kid
it if someone had told my father in 1957
that 50 years in the future his son
would be in the senate
that
teenage immigrant could never have
believed it and and and that but if we
can have conversations then we can say
all right what works what doesn't work
the left is afraid to have those
conversations their ideas don't work
all right there there's a joke i i tell
sometimes which is
how many radical leftists does it take
to screw in a light bulb how many that's
not
funny like it's like guys just relax
like like like
lighten up
and and
you know my
i was talking about in college when when
we were debating we'd go
you know
i he called me a fascist i'd call him a
a uh uh
a communist then we could get a beer
like just you know
not all of life has to be i must destroy
my enemy and there's a lot of that right
now but do you think there's a
fundamental reason for that i think
there actually is that that lefties now
and not always and i actually want to
ask you about what it used to be like
when there was a sort of sane democratic
party
but that there's a fundamental reason
for the the anger and the outrage and
the perpetual craziness which is
they believe government is everything
and that you know this as a senator it's
a pretty freaking messy probably often
miserable game that you have to play
to be to be a politician in america or
probably anywhere and that because their
whole world view is through politics as
opposed to a religious or some other
spiritual world view well of course
you're going to be endlessly miserable
do you think i'm ball parking something
there
so i do
and and it's
you know it's interesting i was talking
the other night to a gentleman he and
his wife came from cuba and came from
cuba
fled under under castro and he was
talking about he said you know
ted you talk about the constitution
quite a bit
and he said i think there are a lot of
people like me who who came from
countries the constitution was
meaningless
and they don't necessarily understand
why that matters and they're a little
bit skeptical of
what
why should the constitution make a
difference and i was agreeing with him
in that we need to explain that more
government power
the history of humanity is largely in a
history of government oppressing the
people
now you need some government not an
anarchist you need government to to
protect your your fundamental rights
to life to liberty to property john
locke wrote wrote about the the
fundamental natural rights you need
government to impose rule of law and you
see countries that don't have that
are disasters
but the more power government has
the less liberty you have and jefferson
had a great way of putting it he
described the constitution
as chains
to bind the mischief of government
um
yeah that's pretty profound yeah you
know free speech
is not about silencing those who
disagree with you
um
religious liberty
it's not about forcing everyone to
practice your faith it's about saying
look it's up to you what faith you
practice or none at all that's that's
that right of conscience that you get to
decide that it's not government that
comes in
you know you just had
all right
you know you talked about abortion you
and i may disagree on abortion but you
just had joe biden a week ago
say if he's elected
he's coming after the little sisters of
the poor no i'm completely against that
by the way i mean i've done videos on it
yeah
i mean
that is an extreme view you literally
have politicians saying those damn
catholic nuns i'm going to go after them
and force them
to pay for abortion inducing drugs and
these are nuns who've taken vows of
poverty and helping the poor and the
sick and the needy
and and government now for
years has been persecuting them
because they must conform and it's just
look i think being libertarian and
living let live giving people like
respecting diversity
solves a lot of the problems we have in
the country
so so speaking of diversity then do you
ever feel it because you mentioned your
father and your family's story
because you're a republican because
you're on the right that in many ways
the people who love to scream about
diversity all day long they've sort of
stolen that from you i i know you don't
wave it as a as a victim card but your
own personal family story and and
because you're you look white
so to speak and because you're on the
right you're you're just a white guy all
right congratulations look i on social
media
it is amazing you look at some of some
of the angry protesters
who who sometimes are
angry angry rich white guys
who are telling everyone look the riots
that that occurred following the
horrific killing of george floyd
many of the neighborhoods that were
burned down were african-american
neighborhoods
some of the most poignant and powerful
videos
were of residents they're crying going
okay you just burned my only grocery
store
you know my k you know african-american
small business owners whose stores were
destroyed
and destroyed by
self-entitled
often middle or upper class kids i
noticed after that first debate when you
were getting googled and everybody was
going well who is this what is this that
suddenly some of the mainstream outlets
so like buzzfeed and huffpo and the rest
of them they were trying to link you to
the alt-right and the trolls and she's
secretly being supported by
conservatives and all that now
me and the people that are doing the
online thing it's like we see this all
the time if you step out of anything
that sort of the the modern left doesn't
want you to do you're automatically the
bad guy but then when i saw it going
after you i was like see they just do
this to everybody yeah yeah i mean it it
started before that to be honest it
started the very
day that i announced my candidacy for
president yeah and it's being anti-war
which is your number one piece as if
that is conservative i mean that's what
they're trying to sell now yeah a
reporter asked me this question
literally just yesterday after the new
hampshire democratic convention
she said well you know
you she's talking about how i've made it
a central focus of my campaign that we
need to end these wasteful
counterproductive wars uh work to end
this new cold war and arms race and
redirect our taxpayer dollars that we've
wasted for so long to the tune of six
trillion dollars since 9 11 alone
redirect those resources back here to
serve the needs of our people to take
care of the urgent concerns people have
whether it's healthcare infrastructure
education
and and her point was well
this sounds like a conservative message
i said what are you talking about right
she said well you know the conservative
message of how do you pay for things
i said are you kidding me yeah i said
i'll tell you what americans across this
country are sick and tired of hearing
from politicians and from their
government that there's not enough money
to make sure that kids in flint kids in
newark kids in communities across this
country can't have clean water to drink
because the government can't make sure
that that infrastructure ensures clean
water you know they're sick and tired of
hearing that you know levees are failing
and there's massive flooding in rural
iowa that's ruining uh farms for their
entire year of crops and they're told
well you know what sorry there's just
not enough money to make sure that this
infrastructure is holding to keep you
and your family safe so this is not a
conservative concern this is an american
concern and it is a call to action
to to change our priorities bring about
this sea change this is why i'm running
for president right to bring the the
leadership and the conviction to stand
up to the foreign policy establishment
the military-industrial complex bringing
the experience that i have both as a
soldier as well as in congress to shift
our priorities to stop this waste and
bring it back to that central focus of
serving the american people yeah it was
just such a fascinating flip yeah
suddenly anti-war they want to sell it
as conservative most people are actually
anti-war i mean i think most people
don't really want to go towards that
being said is trump complicating the
issue for you particularly a little bit
because trump at least from where i'm
sitting has not been pro-war you may not
be happy with some of the some of the
things he's doing but you know he wants
to get us out of afghanistan it doesn't
seem like we're going to be
nation-building so that being the
anti-war candidate is a little trickier
as opposed to if it was if he was just
more of a traditional republican maybe
or even obama who went into libya or
wherever right right i don't i don't i
don't think it makes it tricky at all
um trump campaigned a lot on this
message of ending stupid wars bringing
our troops home calling out saudi arabia
for being
you know one of the biggest supporters
for terrorism that they are the problem
is after he got into office after he got
elected
he chose to surround himself with the
very same neocon warhawks that have been
pushing for more of these
counterproductive regime change wars
for a very long time people like john
bolton people he has now secretary mike
pompeo
and uh i think if we we find ourselves
in the position that we're in where in
fact trump hasn't carried through on the
promises that he made the rhetoric that
he was using during that campaign and
that's where i i find so many people who
are coming to our town hall saying they
feel betrayed because of that because he
has not only not brought our troops home
and yes he's working on getting our
troops home from afghanistan and that is
good for america i wish him success in
doing that they should have come home a
long time ago but we've got more troops
in syria
he and his administration has pushed us
very close to the brink of war with iran
deploying more troops to saudi arabia
and to the region escalating tensions
there
while even though he says on television
that he doesn't want to go to war with
iran every one of his actions has pushed
us to that brink where we sit today
where just a match could light the whole
thing on fire how do you balance the
rhetoric of saying i'm against war
without sort of tipping
to the enemy whoever it may be that
you're not a pushover that that seems to
be one of the things that because i
don't yeah because i don't i don't say
that i'm against i mean nobody wants war
trust me and as a veteran i've seen the
cost of war uh firsthand but i'm very
specific in saying we need to end
these uh wasteful regime change wars
we've got to stop being the world's
police trying to go around the world and
you know pick off which dictators we
don't like and you know
keep and prop up the authoritarian
dictators that that we do like as we've
seen happen throughout our country's
history and the wasteful regime change
wars maintain our national security by
having a ready and capable military and
continue to work to defeat those who
threaten the united states continue to
work to defeat terrorist threats like al
qaeda and like isis and doing so in a
smart and effective way yeah all right
so i want to do a whole bunch on on all
the issues we'll just check off a whole
bunch but i got to just go backwards a
little bit here let's just talk about
what's generally happening uh with the
dnc because i think there's just a
belief out there whether
for democrats republicans it doesn't
matter that the dnc just strikes people
as deeply corrupt they they basically
screwed over bernie last time uh there's
a feeling now that even with you not
being in the debate that it's just
unclear which polls are allowed to be
looked at and which aren't and how they
you know accumulate all of them and look
at the numbers and all that
do you think the dnc is actively working
against you do you think it is corrupt
do you think it is in bed with one of
the other candidates or several of the
other candidates what is happening do
you think what's clear is that this
system lacks transparency the whole
process is lacking transparency and uh
that's the change and that's the reform
that i'm calling for from the dnc in
this because if they're not transparent
with their process and you pointed out
some of the issues
that are coming to light here is you
know well these
small number of polls are qualifying
these other ones are not why is that who
are they actually talking to how many
people are they talking to
there are credible accurate polls that
they're choosing not to recognize and
questionable polls that they are so the
the problem with all of this and i speak
as a as a strong democrat is that it
it creates a lack of trust in democratic
voters that the dnc is actually working
for their interest in creating a very
fair and transparent process and when
you've got a lack of trust then you've
got people who wonder whether or not
they should even be involved at all
whether or not they should show up to
the caucuses and the primaries if the
fix is already in yeah and that that is
sort of how it feels i mean even this
whole thing with super delegates that
ultimately could you know override what
the what the people voted for and the
rest of it and i don't know i know there
was a lot of turnover from four years
ago but i don't know that they've done
the internal
uh checks yeah you know there were a lot
of people were frustrated with what
happened in 2016 who ran for you know
those delegate positions to sit on the
rules committee to try to bring about
some of these changes
um you know
i've been calling for an end to super
delegates
for a while now calling for open
primaries make it so that our system and
our primaries
are open transparent and actually
representative of the votes that people
are casting
we're not anywhere close to where we
need to be
they got rid of super delegates just in
the first ballot
at the convention uh but if there is a
challenge ballot as as you know given a
crowded primary there there may likely
be
then in the second and any ongoing
ballots uh super delegates will come
into play so right so ultimately the
superdelegate delegates still could
override the will of the people which is
the whole problem with with that whole
super delegate system what do you make
just more broadly about just the general
process like when you're on stage and
you know you had that moment that really
caught fire when uh you were really
taking kamala harris to task on on some
of the decisions she made uh related to
criminal justice reform and like that
caught fire and then it's like that you
have to just sort of do that today
that's the problem that i think with
these debates is
it's it's all about the media uh their
ratings and ultimately profits you know
media is money is that just us though
like i complain about the media no but
you don't think it's just that all of us
sort of like when i saw that moment i
was like yeah that's it yeah it's the
breath of the day the sound bite right
but but when you when you have the
candidates who are on the stage and
you're given anywhere from 30 to 60
seconds
to make your case to the american people
about any one of a number of really
important issues that we're facing are
voters really walking away with a good
sense of a depth of understanding on an
issue the clear contrast between the
positions that we hold uh you know there
there are maybe let's say top 10 things
you would do to reform immigration for
example
you don't get to make those points and
make those differences when you've got
these quick little sound bites and the
only thing making news at the end of it
the only thing people are promoting or
remembering are those flash points are
those sound bites that the media
promotes and and and no i don't think
it's just us because i've been hearing
from folks who were seeing out in the
labor day parades and people are saying
you know gosh you did great at the
debate
but i really want to hear more
you know really have an in-depth
conversation with candidates allow us to
be able to make make our case to share
our experience the positions we hold the
vision that we have for this country in
a meaningful way and voters aren't
getting that and and you know you see
some of them saying i'm just i i don't i
don't have time for this i don't get
anything by spending two hours watching
that debate so that's the thing
somewhere else right you don't feel more
educated right after and that's how
generally mainstream media has been
treating us also so these debates end up
being kind of a shurat you know charade
about
um
this is a providing a fair transparent
process for voters to become educated
but none of that's actually happening
joining me today is the junior senator
from kentucky the man that anthony fauci
has endless nightmares about and now i
think it's fair to say a reuben report
regular senator rand paul welcome back
to the reuben report
well thanks for having me uh you had uh
quite a day today another uh fight or
what do we want to call it fight what do
you want to call it i don't want to call
it fight but you got into it without you
again what do you make of this guy he's
just like a purple brawl yeah
and you keep coming back to personal
attacks on me that have absolutely no
relevance to reality do you think
anybody has had more influence let me
finish this than you have do you madam
yes do you think it's a great success
what's happened so far do you think
you're locked down good for our kids do
you think we slowed down the death rate
more people have died now under
president biden than did under president
trump you are the one responsible you
are the architect you are the lead
architect for the response from the
government and now 800 000 people have
died right so you think it's a winning
success what you've advocated for
government
um senator first of all
if you look at everything that i said
you accuse me of in a monolithic way
telling people what they need to do
everything that i've said
has been in support of the cdc
guidelines wear a mask
get boosted and you've added
to make it courses
you've advocated that your infallible
opinion be dictated by law i've always
been pro-vaccine i'm just simply against
authoritarianism and against mandates
the anger that's developed with you dr
fauci is that you don't want to give us
advice you want to tell us what to do
you think you are the science and that
anybody responds to you how dare you
how dare you criticize science as if you
somehow are science
that kind of arrogance that hubris is
really
that's where the anger is coming towards
you
if you were one doctor a man hundreds of
doctors in the government who gave
advice
i don't think anybody people might
object to your advice but there wouldn't
be such a degree of anger but you are so
certain that you're right that you're
not willing to hear anyone else
three epidemiologists of which you are
not even an epidemiologist but three
epidemiologists prominent in their field
oxford stanford and harvard you maligned
them you spoke openly with dr collins
and you did not disagree that let's
paint them as fringe
you went after them and said we will do
a public take down
not in science or nature or lancet in
wired in the nation a left-wing
publication you've engaged in base
politics you wonder why there's so much
anger you're not an objective scientist
you you've lost that long ago and so
many of the things that people want it's
like they want to know why you're
forcing their children to be vaccinated
when 95 of people at risk have been
vaccinated over 95 of people over 65
it's a huge voluntary success and yet
you won't rest until you force every
child to get this so yes there's a great
deal of dissatisfaction with you and
many people want you to go but nobody
wishes you violence
uh no i think he deserves everything he
gets and then some to tell you the truth
i mean we probably never had a
government bureaucrat have this much
power over our lives and this much
disdain for our individual liberty
and really when you've got a government
bureaucrat a government doctor who
believes and will tell you that i am the
science
and any criticism of him is basically
seen as criticizing science can you
imagine the arrogance today went one
step further and he says
if you have the temerity to question him
over him going after these
epidemiologists that wrote the greater
barrington declaration if you have the
temerity to do that you're now guilty
of fomenting violence against him and
it's it's a terrible sort of uh
accusation to make and i reminded him
that look i was there on the ball field
when a bernie sanders supporter almost
killed steve scalise
a staff member was shot less than 10
people 10 feet from me but none of us
blamed bernie sanders for that none of
us really said oh you can blame a
left-wing politician for some crazy
supporter of theirs and yet that's what
he did today the left-wing media lapped
it up
so knowing that the left-wing media
which is basically all the mainstream
media isn't gonna frame any of this in
an honest way it does seem that the
narrative is collapsing for the people
that are paying attention that a lot of
the stuff that you've been talking about
for quite some time is starting to
bubble up you know they're sort of
admitting you get the vaccine it doesn't
quite work the way it was promised the
mass don't work well like promise the
blocks down lockdowns don't work like
promise are you feeling that there is an
actual momentum shift and what do you
think that'll look like at a national
level if so
you you may have seen this in the last
year or two that some people suspected
that the death count was inflated that
many people were dying with kovid and
not from kovid
wow the biden administration has woken
up to this fact and we're getting
regular pronouncements from them day to
day they said yesterday
75 of the people dying have four
comorbidities meaning they're pretty
sick people and that many of them are
dying with covid as an incidental
finding all right he came in he lost his
arm his leg and
his ear was cut off from an automobile
accident and he also tested positive
from kovid but he died from internal
bleeding but he also had coveted but see
when they're waking up to it and when
you have cnn doctors saying
cloth masks are nothing more than facial
decoration guess what maybe yeah they
are i think
understanding that there are more deaths
under biden than they were under trump
that they got some explaining to do and
their best way is to explain this as
something we're going to have to live
with how much of the negligence do you
think at this point trickles up to biden
and i'm saying that specifically that
way that it trickles up to him because i
don't think he really has a good handle
on what's going on here but you know
we've all seen the videos a month or two
ago if you get the jab you know you're
gonna you're not gonna spread covet et
cetera et cetera you won't catch covet
that's obviously not the truth i mean
what has to happen to some of these
people i from biden to fouchy to
wallensky at the cdc etc
if it's trickling up to him it would
have to be mashed and made for
edentulous food that you feed to the
elderly i mean i don't think he's in
charge of a whole lot of things i would
say that um he's indirectly responsible
for it because he did say over and over
again he was going to not lock the
economy down he was going to lock the
virus down and now more people have died
under his watch he did blame president
trump he says he's responsible for these
200 000 people dying it was a ridiculous
statement and no honest politician
should have been allowed to get away
with it and the media should have gone
at him and said that's not fair and yet
the media bought into it and it was the
narrative that the virus was trump's
fault but now the virus goes on and
seems to be really uncontrollable um in
the death's mount now it's sort of well
you need to accept it really the cloth
masks don't work they're trying to find
a way to get back to normal because
guess what the blame is attaching to
them but almost all of the things that
you see are from government planning
government policy and socialism
they're in charge of the testing
they're the ones that are mandating how
we do the test so everybody's got to get
a test so if your five-year-olds got
covid and you really wouldn't know it
but you test them and they've got
covered now you got to test the whole
class then you got to test all their
siblings then you got to test all their
parents so this thing sort of spreads
out its tentacles spread through society
and the government will say oh we're not
for lockdowns but we are for testing
everybody if you test everybody
inevitably it leads to a lockdown
so this is a real problem most of the
people on the hearing today without you
like oh why can't the government make
more tests i'm like why the hell are we
ordering so many tests this is about
ordering too many tests and it's about
testing people who are not sick people
who are not sick should not quarantine
and people are not sick shouldn't be
taking tests or medicines we should
leave them the hell alone but that's our
real problem and who gave us all this
advice falchi
you know so biden's taking falchi's
advice but fauci is the problem so i
mean i think i know your answer to this
but should fauci just step down i mean
it doesn't seem to me that this is a guy
who should be running the nih anymore i
mean it's enough's enough already
i mean if we don't have room for him in
prison i mean stepping down would
probably be okay but no he's a menace in
the sense that uh
he really is careless and callous
towards our liberty he uh his first
impulse is always an authoritarian one
but he also ignores the science so by
conservative estimates over 100 million
americans have gotten this 62 million on
the official website have gotten coveted
but the nih has studies that say five
people for every person diagnoses at
least five people undiagnosed
let's say it's only one or two we still
get to well over 100 million maybe half
of america has been infected if you
don't count them then you think we're
woefully short on vaccines then you
mandate it on children
but the other thing there you know you
would never know this by watching cnn or
any of these other
networks that are full of fake news
if you look at how many people have been
infected naturally and you say well how
many people have gotten the vaccine
95 of people over 65 have been
vaccinated it's even higher if you go
above 75.
the the voluntary vaccine has been an
enormous success but if you watch cnn
you think oh gosh nobody's been
vaccinated the truth is the opposite
almost everybody that's at risk for this
disease has been vaccinated the children
are getting it naturally whether you
vaccinate them or not now adults are
getting it whether you vaccinate them or
not really we're headed towards where
there's going to be enough immunity
within the community and i think the the
devolving nature of this is towards a
cold we have four other coronaviruses
that cause the cold this is going to
become the fifth coronavirus the sooner
the better and then we also at the same
time we'll have some people dying the
vulnerable people let's try to save them
by getting government obstacles out of
the way so we can have more monoclonals
again and more of the new pills
but also let's repurpose some of the
things that we have out there that
lessen inflammation what's it like for
you as a republican congressman in this
crazy state just just going around as a
conservative in blue
california you know what's interesting
if i'm on a plane and i'm flying to
florida there's people on my autograph
in texas they'll cheer me yeah yeah in
california new york they'll yell at me
right but that's okay that's okay
what's happening is is something i
haven't seen in quite some time look in
california we've had republicans and
democrats
who have managed this state and i firmly
believe
if we could change the top two system
i know why people want to put in the top
two system i never supported it but the
top two system takes us away from having
a debate about ideas
so what's happening in the top two
system we're not getting the very best
people to run
because
think about this one of the most popular
governors in the country is a guy named
baker in massachusetts he's a republican
do you know there's not one republican
congressman from massachusetts it's
overwhelmingly democrat but they
re-elect this
governor maryland right but what's
happening in california you're not
getting the quality people to run
because the top two people think there's
not enough republicans but if we let the
parties decide on at least all the
constitutional offices we would have a
debate of ideas and i what i truly
believe in california people would want
to check and balance that the
legislature is so far it's not
democratic it's socialist right this
wing has gone so far
that they would want to check and
balance that if they got out of control
they have somebody in governor who would
veto the bill
i think a republican could win governor
each and every time in california i
think an attorney general republican
could win
target closes their stores in san
francisco neiman marcus they just run it
and why these are the democratic
policies that have now been implemented
because they won the majorities now
we're seeing the outcome that is why the
pendulum will swing why do you think
democrats can't seem to
associate the people that they vote for
in the policies they vote for for the
bad stuff that happens like all the
people in san francisco right now that
are watching the neiman marcus video
that we played it on the show and just
people running into walmart and into
walgreens i think 17 walgreens closed in
the san francisco area just stealing
stuff and then you've got the d.a that
won't prosecute and then now we've got
the former san francisco d.a is now in
los angeles i mean you get it's the swa
it's a mini swamp that we've got here in
california but for some reason people
can't seem to realize oh if you keep
voting in the same party and things keep
going wrong that there's maybe a
connection there to the people you're
voting in is it the sun it's the it's
the weather right it's friday
you know what i think i think it's a
combination
i don't think these are the democrats of
old
i mean if you study history oh i know
i wrote the book yeah there weren't
there were democrats who weren't crazy
there were democrats who were
conservative right if you took jerry
brown's father
if you compare jerry brown who i think
is liberal compared to gavin he didn't
he seemed more conservative but what
what i found now is
they have they have shifted they have
become
a socialist marxist idea and that wing
of the party has become more powerful
and the moderate ring of the party is
afraid and they can't win anymore are
you surprised how quickly they folded
that's one of the things i'm just
focused on all the time that they i
don't think in his heart of hearts that
chuck schumer is a true like radical
leftist or or even nancy posey i don't
really think that he's afraid of him
she is yeah okay okay but but pelosi
actually gets that i say that with no
love for her that was like trying to
give like a little bit of credit that i
don't think she's like over the top aoc
but you know what they're afraid she's
no she's jealous of aoc
she believes she was
the founding liberal she's from san
francisco she's the founder and they
think of this aoc has more followers
than pelosi when aoc got elected to
congress remember she wanted i get the
number wrong she only won and only had
to have like no it's a tiny amount of
money yeah yeah but here she is and she
has a name brandon she she had more
followers in pelosi she was giving
pelosi problems
so what did the speaker of the house do
had a meeting with her
and then took a picture yeah you know
who put the picture out not aoc pelosi
because she believes aoc is stronger and
then look at this
in the last election pelosi saying she's
going to win 15 seats she got the number
right the party wrong it's the first
time since 94 not no republican lost and
we beat 15 democrats but the interesting
part is there is only one wing of the
democratic party that grew
police has a five-seat majority the
smallest has been in 100 years
but the corey bush the aoc the talibs
the omars
that wing the social swing of the party
grew stronger
they won and pelosi lost
so how do you take the house back
well we take the house back exactly what
we did in the last election okay
and you've got to analyze it
in the last election
had we not had coveted trump would have
won re-election okay
any historical factor you go through
pandemics the leaders normally have a
challenge
the senate
we really thought republicans would win
and think about that you only needed one
seat to win in georgia right you had two
and you lost yeah
people could call malpractice on that
right because think about it if you look
you're trying to get me booted from
youtube no no no but if you run
as a republican in georgia you start
with a four-pointed advantage yeah okay
in the house everyone believed we'd lose
15 seats even our own even our own
pollsters thought we'd lose but think
about this we win in 2010 we beat 63
democrats not every incumbent wins so in
this last election with all the wind
against us
every single incumbent wins
but we beat 15 democrats every democrat
lost to a republican woman a republican
minority we elected more republican
women than any time in the history of
the party okay
so now
only two times in the history of the
country has the party in power meaning
whoever controlled the white house lose
the white house and gained seats in the
house 1892 and 1992 and both times they
won the majority two years later
okay
31
731 votes
that's how short we came up from winning
the majority out of more than 152
million
so what what really happened there was
about four or five seats i didn't have
enough money we didn't play in and we
lost by less than two points people
didn't quite see what was happening at
the silent majority that's why when you
talk about can we win the recall in
california yes i don't care what the
pollsters say because momentum
the next election is going to be big
right because all of these things about
defunding the police
they're all go all these democrat
policies that are now going in place
we're seeing the outcome the woke-ism
the open border the inflation
where we're going to have the biggest
victory school boards
we haven't been paying attention for the
last 20 years critical race theory goes
against everything martin luther king
has ever told us don't judge us by the
color of our skin and now they're
embracing it right they're going
backwards and the interesting part here
is okay
something else is happening not just an
election and it'll be a national
election for congress what history says
is the party in power whoever wins the
white house on the first off year
election loses 27 seats we lost 40 obama
lost 63.
so that's and they have a five-seat
advantage in the last election cycle
we we targeted about 50 democrats only
one retired okay
this cycle already five democrats have
retired and i'll bet you that gets over
10. if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell